[Music]
I'm going to talk you a bit about the
activities of machine learning at star
lab for doing brain health startup is
when this is the outline of the talk I
will give you a bit of the context of
the company and then I will give you an
overview of application of machine
learning in in health and healthcare and
then I will give you three examples of
how do we use at star lab machine
learning for health applications all
focus on brain health which is our topic
so star lab is basically a company a
technology transfer company that tries
to transform scientific results into
products or services that have a
positive impact in society and the main
focus of of the company is this one the
electrical the electrical brain this
should be
I stink it well it's basically the fact
that the fact that the brain the
stimulants are transforming the brain
into electricity and this data in form
of electricity goes from one part of the
other of the brain in form of electrical
impulses so this allows us on the one
hand to read the brain activity and on
the other hand to apply electrical
stimulation to modify and to modulate
this electrical activity I will talk a
bit about this but mostly I'm focusing
on how do we measure this electrical
activity with devices that we have
developed in the past and which is the
kind of systems that we are applying on
them so I'm talking about basically
bring health brain health it's it's a
set of diseases that affects 20% of the
world population we are talking about
epilepsy we are talking about
neurodegenerative diseases or mental
health like in the case of depression
and there is a fundamental need which is
the fact that most of these diseases are
based on the subjective evaluation of
the symptoms so and this is a problem
probably because of this fact the
development of drugs for seeing CNS
treatment central nervous system
treatments are the riskiest business in
the pharma company so they have the
lowest chance of approval at regulatory
stages and they have the longest
development years and because of that
this is the most expensive business in
all the activities of the pharma
companies so we try to help here
by providing biomarkers that are based
on electrical activity and we are doing
this in a set of different funded
projects where we developed
it concepts that we turn them into
products and I will show you some
examples about that so basically what we
have is basically a brain that generates
electrical activity we record this
activity with some devices that are
called EEG electroencephalography that
turn this electrical activity in the
brain into digital signals and with
these digital signals what we do after
is apply machine learning algorithms to
provide different services why is this
interesting so applying machine learning
in health I will give you some data for
instance the 48 percent increase
annually in health care data so we are
talking about genetic data we are
talking about neuro imaging but also
electronic health records so this is a
very interest in fact this is maybe the
reason why in the magazine Forbes was
forecasting that in 2019 artificial
intelligence big data analytics and
related technologies will have a very
profound impact in in health care not
only from the business point of view but
also from the scientific point of view
this graph is a plot of the years from
2005 to 2009 teen of the number of
publications in PubMed which is a
repository of medical science papers
these are the numbers of publications
that mention machine or deep learning or
that comment or present works on machine
learning and deep learning so there is
an exponential growth and they in the
top six specialities of this profusion
of machine and deep learning algorithms
there are neurology psychiatry
psychology this is important to take
into account not only these but also the
FDA approved applications in the last
years have increased
so 39 applications are approved and some
of them exactly eight people 18% are
applications for neurology psychology
psychiatry and include for instance
diagnosis of sleep disorders memory
assessment in the elderly or autism
diagnosis and this is also all following
a trend in the in the field which is
called bio low Biological Psychiatry
which is basically trying to come from a
subjective evaluation based diagnosis to
a data-driven one which fits very well
in the purposes of machine learning so
for what can we use digital markers and
this is an interesting paper in natural
neuroscience of 2017 and offers a very
clear scheme of how can you use these
digital markers in the healthcare domain
so basically you can do early detection
of diseases you can do diagnosis
differential diagnosis as well and you
can predict the treatment outcome and
CNS drug development I will show you now
three activities that are related with
these three different application fields
of these digital markers of works and
projects that we have developed at
sturla and I will start which one which
is for the early detection in
Parkinson's disease so our aim after
having developed the machine learning
system is to provide a decision support
system for clinicians so you cannot see
the video unfortunately but basically
what you have here is a subject a
patient suffering from a disease or
sleep disease that's called REM behavior
disorder if you have this disease
basically you have no inhibition of your
muscle activity during the REM sleep
while you are dreaming and therefore you
start moving you start injuring your bed
partner
so it's a grave disease that appears
more or less when you are 60 years old
and the patients of this disease later
on in average eight years later develop
either Parkinson's disease in 30 percent
of the cases or dementia with Lewy
bodies with which is a particular type
of dementia or remain RVD so the idea of
applying machine learning here is oh are
we able to predict by having that eg
that a brain activity data of the people
being diagnosed as RVD are we able to
probe knows there no degenerative
disease eight years later so that was
the purpose of the grants that we apply
for the Michael J Fox foundation in the
States and we develop a study with seven
different partners all over the world
trying to develop this integrated
platform for collecting their EEG data
repositories centralizing them and
applying machine learning on this on
this data the machine learning system
has not a lot of secrets so I mean it's
follows the usual structure of a machine
learning system you have a state for
feature extraction you have a stage for
feature selection then you have a
classifications stage that tries to
transform what the original raw EEG data
into a subject score into a risk score
for doing the diagnosis of RVD or the
prognosis of the neural degeneration so
trying to give you a risk score that you
will develop this no degenerative
disease and in some cases also which one
of them Parkinson's or dementia with
Lewy bodies for analyzing each data
basically you follow similar approach as
you do with all the data you split all
the spectrum which is what you have here
this is the spectra of the EEG signals
in the different groups and you split
the
speak this a spectra into different
frequency bands and you compute the
power in these different feature
frequency bands and this is what you use
as the features for your system so you
have 14 different channels in your eg
and you have 13 protein savants so you
have a feature space of 182 components
therefore we have developed a feature
selection stage and I will present very
briefly here one of the methodologies
that we have applied for a feature
selection which is based on deep out
encoders basically we have a network of
three decreasing layers in
dimensionality and three increasing
layers in dimensionality where you try
to map the input and the output and
since the intermediate layer has reduced
dimensionality than the input space what
you will do is use the activity in this
intermediate layer for making the input
in the classification which is in our
case a support vector machine and these
are the performance measures when
comparing with our rapper or a filtering
approach of the de Pantone coder as you
can see it outperforms the other
approaches but it has a problem in
operational conditions and it's the
computational cost one interesting
aspect of the system is that we are
using methodology which is called leaf
per subjects out or leaf out which was
proposed in 2010 which is basically you
take one example of class the positive
class and one example of the negative
class and this is your validation test
what allows this is to give a better
estimation of the performance when you
have small datasets it allows you which
is very interesting to compute the area
under the curve without having to go
through the representation of the rocks
and it keeps balance in the training set
because you are taking one example of
each of the classes so what you have
here is the subjects of one class the
subjects of the other class and the
obtained performance in terms of area
under the curve when you are testing the
system another aspect I wanted to
commend is basically the fact that there
are a lot of ways of computing
performance measures if you take here
you have three different accuracy
measures of your system all show a Cudas
in your system but basically the
different figures depend on the way you
are conducting the validation and on the
way you are normalizing the scores and
this is often an aspect that it's not
very well disclosed in the papers in the
literature so take into account this
basically these are the results with a
data set of 200 subjects of RBD you can
see here the performance measures for
instance I will underscore the result of
the conversion prognosis distinguishing
those patients that remain RBD from
those that develop the neurodegeneration
with a performance of 82 percent in
terms of area under the curve and 91% of
right
detected subjects so in 91 percent of
the subjects we are able to write
predict if they are going to convert
into Parkinson disease or dementia with
Lewy bodies another interesting aspect
is to use the output of the classifiers
as it could be another biomarker use in
clinical research and so for this it's
interesting to give you not only the
performance but also the effect size of
your of your system what we are trying
to do with this machine learning system
is integrated in a decision support
system all the development is very
interesting from the point of view of a
machine learning
from the data science point of view but
the problem is if you don't have an
outer protective dirac what is the sense
of telling a subject that he will or she
will develop another degeneration in
eight years so the business case for
such a decision support system in the
case of prognosis it's very difficult so
not everything its intellectual work but
also trying to find a way of making this
useful I'm going to present you very
briefly our work on a VHD as you may
know ADHD is a disease pediatric disease
mostly pediatric disease although there
are also adults suffering from ADHD and
that has a very large misdiagnosis rates
of ten to twenty two percent so
basically what we are trying to provide
is a diagnosis for knowing based on data
if these children or these adults are
suffering from ADHD for this we are
using a very particular type of neural
network which is called an echo state
network it has three layers an input
layer and output one and in the middle
it has a so-called reservoir which is a
fully connected layer that randomly
connects one node to the other it's a
type of recurrent neural network and
basically the hypothesis is that we can
discover chaotic synchronization between
eg channels I will talk a bit about this
if you have two linear systems coupled
linearly what you will find out is a
synchronised system so this would be one
variable the other variable the
relationship is linear then you can
apply correlational analysis and it will
give the level they deliver you a
correlational coefficient but if you
have two chaotic systems couple you have
another type of synchronization which is
called generalizing
zatia which deliver such a form this
will be one variable this will be the
other one and the question in all the
world was can we use this type of
recurrent neural network to characterize
to a time series that are chaotic
related this has you have conducted a
theoretical study that you can find in
the journal cows and we have tried to
apply this concept to generate a marker
for ADHD this is our data set for 251
children 21 with ADHD 30 with controls
and basically what we are trying to do
in the system is to we have intervals
where the children are closing their
eyes we are measuring the electrical
activity and other intervals where the
children are opening their eyes and we
use the echo state network to find out
which are the intervals in which the
person is opening eyes and which is the
intervals in which they are closing
their eyes and we use a performance
measure as a measure of the connectivity
of the generalized synchronization
between two channels in the EEG so I'm
going a bit into details because I've
heard that some people were complaining
about lack of content so I'm trying to
give a bit more of this after doing this
this particular connectivity matrix can
be used to distinguish one group the
ADHD from the healthy controls with a
significance with a statistical
significance that you have to correct
for multiple comparisons and this has
the liver and other paper which
hopefully will be published in
psychiatry research I'm going to change
a bit the scope I will going to present
you another project a research project
that we are coordinating from Star lab
which is a consciousness
study it is a vet project basically that
has the vision that consciousness human
consciousness will be someday measure by
means of measuring the electrical
activity in the brain and also that we
can alter it consciousness levels by
applying electrical stimulation this is
a bit of the background on consciousness
you have here different states of
consciousness display in a plot that
it's used in Neurology you have here
comma P these two dimensions are wake
wakefulness and awareness you have
states of coma so where you don't have
wakefulness you don't have any awareness
and you have conscious wakefulness here
and in between you have other states
like for instance different sleep stages
here you have lucid dreaming which is a
state in which you have high awareness
because you are aware of the content of
your dreams but you are sleeping so
that's why the index of wakefulness is
here and you have other states related
with coma mean minimally conscious state
and vegetative state where the subjects
are awake but they are not aware so what
we are trying to do here and what it's
related with a machine learning system
is a system related with that type of
treatment that we are developing based
on non-invasive brain stimulation we
apply an electrical an electrical field
in the skull in the cortex and we are
expecting this electrical field to
change this minimal conscious state
patients into wakeful and patients so we
are conducting this study with a coma
science group in Liege basically I have
applied this treatment to their patients
from which six out of 46 patients were
responding positively to this treatment
and the question for the machine
learning is
are we able to predict those patients
that will respond positively from those
that won't respond positively because if
I know in advance then I don't need to
go through the therapy for these
patients which are very complex to treat
so this is another type of digital
marker the one that it's acting for
predicting the treatment outcome
basically we are taking the EEG the
electrical activity before the treatment
and we are applying the regular machine
learning system so we are splitting
again the EEG signals into different
frequency bands you have here a PC a
protection of the non-responding the red
class versus the responding class which
is quite mixed if we use another type of
approach which is these t s and E we can
do also a protection of the feature
space that delivers this other plot
which is basically you have the
responding in green the non-responding
in red and as you see this is a problem
where you have a circle in the middle
and then so more or less the other
things around and therefore we thought
we may be using support vector machines
this is a video I cannot display but as
you can remind or recall support vector
machines are good in turning nonlinear
classification problems into linear ones
and that's why we apply it here in this
case we apply leaf one subject out
validation so we are taking always all
the data of one subject out of the
training phase because we think this is
part of the these are reflecting the
operational conditions where you are
going to use your system later on so
basically there will be a subject that
were with whose data has not been used
for train that will be presented to the
machine learning system and the area
under the curve in this case in 100
repetitions of this cross for validation
stage was more or less 84 percent of
area under the curve okay and now to
finish some take-home messages just to
remember for what can you use digital
markers not only of eg activity but also
from wearables from other types of data
that it's related with your health you
can use them for every detection I show
you how to use it in Parkinson's early
detection you can use it for
differential diagnosis in the as in the
case of ADHD and you can use them also
for predicting treatment outcome not
only in the case of non-invasive brain
stimulation but also of drug treatments
and I would like to thank all the people
of the team which have developed parts
of the work that I am presenting today
these are their names the members of the
neuroscience business unit and I would
like to thank you everybody for for your
attention thank you very much question
on the EEG related work can you get
localized information from the your EEG
data to be able to differentiate what
part of the brain your signals are
coming from yes you can do by applying
source localization approaches which
basically project your activity in the
cortical surface or what reading the
electrodes into other parts of the brain
but since the dimensionality of the
space in your inner space of the brain
is much larger than your electrode space
you need a large number of electrons
however we have been able to apply such
approaches with 16 electrodes so and
then with this projection into deeper
areas what you can do is correlate for
in danger for instance we have used it
in the case of the Parkinson's
project we have correlated one
particular cluster in the spatial domain
with the neuro image with the neuro
imaging modalities that we have and they
are localized in the same place so it's
a kind of validation
thank you for interesting speech tell me
please why do you use a host state
neural network in your model we are
interested in using echo state network
because we think that the type of
relationship between the two time series
of two channels in the EEG are not
related linearly as in this case but we
they are related in a generalized
synchronized way so they present this
type of form when you relate one to the
other so basically if you think of EEG
activity this is coming from some D
poles that are oscillating in your brain
and they relate to each other with we
expect to relate to each other with this
type of generalized synchronization and
therefore we think that a recurrent
neural network will be able to
characterize this kind of
synchronization I noticed that in the
beginning you mentioned as a number of
disease related mental disease I also
noticed which cannot disease mental
disease right I also noticed depression
which has very large numbers but I did
not notice later on your build model for
that so did I miss it out or or is too
complex to build and we are not missing
anything we are missing the data so so
basically for having or developing this
kind of systems you have to count with
data set that it's important not only a
data set related with depression but in
our case also eg data set and this is
something that we don't have so far we
are conducting now a clinical trial in
the UK
for treating depression with electrical
stimulation of the brain and then we
expect to have this data set these EEG
data set to develop such a system for
the efficient decision support another
question so what do you see is the role
of brain computer interfaces in both the
treatment and I guess the research of
the different disorders that you guys
are looking into yeah a brain computer
interfaces are being used for
rehabilitation of stroke they are being
used as traditionally for communication
of computer with any kind of devices
with chairs computers one the problem of
this kind of systems first is the
relevant reliability second is the
business case because normally people
that need this kind of brain computer
interfaces are people that are very much
paralyzed and this is our very low
prevalence diseases and therefore for a
company is very difficult to based to
base the business case on a very low
prevalence disease for the
rehabilitation of stroke I think there
are better possibilities because this is
a larger prevalence and we expect to
develop brain computer interface to a
larger level and then to transfer to
translate into systems also for
communication for this paralyzed
patients however we are using very much
one particular modality of brain
computer interface which is effective
computing this is something that we are
using very much and that we have a large
demand on this kind of system these are
systems that are able to measure the
emotional responses are subject in front
of a stimulus it can be an advertisement
it can be an online
biding process it can be a product it
can be dragons so all these are cases
that we have developed in the past for
clients and this kind this particular
case of brain computer interface this
has a very interesting applicability in
the real world I have a comment about a
Parkinson's disease did you think about
incorporating other variables like for
example age in the in the predictor
because H is actually very important I
mean there is some natural new the
degenerative processes that go on in the
brain that can help you even improve the
those models it's included in the in the
predictors that you have at the moment
no not at the moment so what we have
conducted so far is only with the eg
data but of course anybody able that
will help to increase with the
performance would help but the most
important problems at this stage are not
so much the performance but first the
regulatory process validating your
diagnosis or the decision support system
and the other problem is who is
interested in the system and who will
pay for this system these are the two
main problems that we face at the moment
in the Parkinson decision support system
more than increasing performance that
it's something that we think that we can
achieve by incorporating other variables
or any other type of data I think on the
validation it is known that Parkinson
disease about has about a 50%
misdiagnosis rate is actually very
difficult to diagnose the disease there
are a lot of mistakes done by the
doctors with quick assessments even in
your data sets so you're running against
that problem because your goal stand
already for training is not you know
gold standard per se so I think your
numbers are performing well for what it
what the data that you have yes this is
a circular problem so in the sense that
if you are using supervised approaches
then what you are doing is basically
reproducing the diagnosis that a doctor
has done a diagnosis that includes as
well a misdiagnosis rate in the case of
ADHD 22% in the case of Parkinson's 50%
so to which extent are really useful
these supervised approaches for
developing this kind of system so we ask
ourselves and we are trying to find also
solutions to this by changing to other
kind of approaches I think it's when
biology will provide some blood based
biomarkers that you can use as gold
standards even if there are invasive
tests today then you can train your
models and in the future we don't need
to do those invasive tests anymore we
just can really rely on the on the own
on the digital biomarkers yeah but if
you think also in the way you group the
data when you analyze a biomarker the
grouping of the data is done based on
the diagnosis on the original diagnosis
of course if you have a misdiagnosis Rea
and you don't have enough sample size
this will be reproduced as well in the
in the biomarker no in the fish in the
physiological or in the biological one
taking an egg
[Music]